she's efficient she's hoping you have
core vision you can see what's going on
here
hi guys never afraid something did not
know no you know it's different now I'm
in a bathroom you can't have an echo no
not the delightful new Amazon seek to do
things device that the government very
easily hacked just FYI I've heard rumors
is one o'clock in the morning I get in a
car at 7:30 the mornings to get her a
plane to go home I just went for a jog
in the gym because that's what I do when
I'm stressed out and I just took a
shower because it's been a minute I
wanted my Facebook page to ask you guys
what you would do today until mentioned
that coin team had just done that do
your makeup with a fidget spinner
challenge and that I should try to do
that but in France and do not have a
[ __ ] spinner but here's my logic the
dissenters of those devices that are
used to call man's ayat II and help
settle a restless mind so I don't have
food spinner but I have something that I
used to call my anxiety and settle my
Restless mind bottle champagne I got
this bottle for free on a guide to this
hotel because they're going to be two
people here instead of one note the less
the merrier so I thought I would try and
do my makeup using bottled champagne and
no I did not drink all the champagne
already I'm not a monster but the rest
of it in this tea kill perfect tend to
do our makeup this is where I stopped
thinking through this idea so here we go
hazel service foundation and put
moisturizer on my face
maybe that's cheating already sue me
please don't I'm going to use the bigger
end to do foundation since that's the
most amount of makeup to put in my face
see if there was some champagne left in
the bottle Alan's going to take some
foundation just oh yeah put it right on
there a good hack if you like friggin
makeup sponge but you don't forget to
order room service champagne by yourself
your hotel here we go oh yes section
feels really nice and cool I'm really
going to try this so you guys know oh it
hurts run into the neck you don't want
to look like an idiot
it was really nice and cooling so sort
of the most wedding China all of my
anger toxins saj is it
crazy I'm a content creator what did you
go to college for hmm okay really
smearing it all over this kind of thing
at real drunk and came home at the end
of the night fell asleep singing this
was a human man googleman neck you will
output a modern millennial female please
take over the world
alright I mean this is ever their own
color foundation but that's the least of
our concerns right now
that's one under-eye concealer no no I
have this guy which has dick I saw in
Colleen's that she used stick and we're
just going to try and put it on put some
on and they're all around the rim and
I'm gonna apply it to our other eyes
good tap it
oh yeah gentle this hurts actually also
kind of refreshing Andrews residual
champagne on the lip of this which feels
like burning kiddies pee right oh oh
transformation any other liquors out
there that want some red deals and wide
open because we all know champagnes not
gonna like ooh wow who's sleepy and his
under-eye circles not me over what what
next let's contour oh no I only have
powder contour right well here we go
this is dick distance more like a
scraping that's happening and then oh
wow that looks great chisel that
cheekbone real quick it dipped it whoo
okay Wow
oh really
and dirty looking nice Wow we just
weren't able to choose this is blend oh
girl yes this is not oh here's one I am
so standards are the opposite of a
college student right now they are not
high maybe that's good it's enough that
blush crave my cheaper blush you know
the blush I got for free about that
blush oh just in with a tie scraped
every makeup artist out there is like ah
smile because you are an adult doing
something important okay that looks like
have rosacea perfect Lulu London I mean
it's different than how it started now
if you are shadow their little eyeshadow
palette here we got wet start with this
light color scrapes big statement just
sweeps all make three different grapes
grapes grapes calm laugh great screams
careful just some kind of floor pour
some out for the homey school and knock
you on the crease shadow because we have
kids were taking this darker and there's
some a disc darker I'm just going to
find our creation ohyeah ohyeah why is
it going up into my eyebrows get out
like I'm telling you my husband same
guys clean up oh you know I'm going to
use the rounded top part that's more of
the shape of my crease like stampin nope
okay because it blend and get a real -
yeah real natural crease well how come
did someone order a crumbling good
because you shouldn't be able to order
pathways that's very disgusting okay
alright okay with a stamp I know
okay cool I'm serious you can do this
notice blend you ever want any candy
doesn't video she's very adamant about
blending being a major step that you
can't skip when applying makeup a lot of
us don't at the time energy into
blending but it really makes the
difference as you can see Wow and their
fellow eyebrows and gel eyebrow stuff
here to trash can over uses alright that
wasn't as bad as it can be I'll shoot
interested rule knows Cara Belgium
Donald elevated eyebrows code am Odeon
the best part about this makeup is that
I don't have any makeup watch with me
and right now a couple days ago hey I'm
also wearing a bathing suit as a bra
because I ran out of underwear too yay
oh and I did not run out of look
beautiful but here I can't do with his
bottle so I'm just going to put my mask
on and it's not really cheating because
I look crazy Pope did that when I got to
use in my hands capable at home as that
when a ruined whole look
lip I got to lift off or don't put it on
the butt of the bottle just who doesn't
like a little ass kissing kept going all
right but it's champagne what am i doing
but I put it on the mouth of the bottle
because this is a very natural position
for me to be in oh okay there we go
there's my final look you know I think
the wet hair might be throwing it off so
give it a chance
take it in Wow
I'm saying kind of better than I thought
it was going to be you guys like this
video give a thumbs up let me know what
other kind of videos you want to see for
me don't forget to follow me on all my
social media platforms and subscribe to
this YouTube channel why not it's not
the worst time rent a bathroom drinking
champagne putting makeup on her face
using the champagne bottle we're fun
ready for the airport no I don't think
I'll be stopped at customs
we'll see can you see the tripod smear
that your on your arm or this mirrors
dirty there too there's tissue box
there's two really good phone fishes
rates that happen there's a pot and
there's a stool on top of a counter and
I MIDI 'lt resource